[Music]
in hit me baby one more time that's you
wanna pipe one more time
submitted by a training chopstick
training I know those are like so
imagine chopsticks but the tops are like
yeah put together I did two down before
oh really yeah oh we actually had this
thing where you put on oh we took it to
Japan it was like this blue little thing
then you put it on the chopsticks and
create the chopsticks that for kids
because they don't have the Oh a female
singer sparked outrage after releasing a
song suggesting women love being
physically abused by their husbands and
- what understands women
shut up you mean men huh you mean men I
don't know many guys I want to beat up
the girlfriends or wives exactly I don't
know many women that want to get beat up
by men I mean unless it's in bed yeah
saying that's so gross girls like abuse
what that oh maybe that's not abuse in
the butt okay wait no not in my butthole
but like smack my ass here yes the
spanking the spiders when it's playful
is in good taste abuse is okay it's the
intention it's time doing it because
it's not an anger that's a boost that's
that's mean if you're doing it out of
passion slap her in the [ __ ] face
just have the face of brass knuckles
with passion we're not in the air
because I actually thought that your
once and thing started ringing Mills
like a choker while you're having sex
see that's different
you can't just talk her and put up
against the wall without the without the
wiener inside that makes it abuse inside
then it's okay well it's
that's the number one it was consent
when the winner you have an
understanding where both parties like to
roleplay in the violent realm and
there's a safe word and there's and and
she enjoys the choking but the penis is
inside and obviously you're role-playing
and she's saying no but she doesn't mean
no she's saying I like to pretend that
I'm resisting because I ain't no ho but
I am a hole because I like to be treated
like a hole then it's okay and if you
are choking and she can't say anything
instead of a safety word have a safety
object like fart no no like when you
hold something and then if she lets it
go wow you sound so experienced oh gotta
be specific but I feel like because she
can't see anything sometimes you know
say she has to let go of it but when
she's just hold this object the world or
vice versa whatever I make it's a good
stress ball you just you've got to be on
the same page or else it's rape yeah or
abuse so make sure y'all on the same
page yeah okay yeah so there's a female
Moroccan singer welcome her name is and
I'm trying to pronounce this Mane bent
and whole lot that's pretty yeah I don't
know much about Morocco but I did work
at a mortgage firm and then one of my
co-workers was like I'm a Moroccan Jew
and I was like cool yeah I don't I
didn't I don't know I didn't know what
they were I don't know there are ups
there are upstairs on the roof smoking
cigarettes and then I was like oh what
language is that
and then he's like oh I'm a Moroccan Jew
and I was like okay yeah I don't know
anything about Moroccans or Morocco at
all I had a friend that a Adam rockin
restaurant with his family and it came
out what they came to us our belly
dancing and they ate with their hands
and then he had diarrhea after not
though fast don't a bunga that's all I
know I do it because it's his story was
completely irrelevant to anything
Morocco
connections yeah we're children I'm
trying to be whole truly like see you
know that under cuisine and eat with
their hands yeah I mean what if it's
like the fortune cookie in a Chinese
restaurant it might not even be
authentic no it's authentic diarrhea
means it's authentic no wow if you eat
Mexican food you got diarrhea ah Fanta
if you eat Mexican food no diary what
the hell's with this [ __ ] Gringo's the
grosser the better like when you eat
Vietnamese food full and there's no
there's no a thumb in your fault that's
not all flies yep toilet in the air or
like you're digging in a soup and by the
time you're done with it you find the
little wing yeah that come from if you
go to a Chinese restaurant and there's
no like the owners little kid isn't
studying in the divided off area with
the [ __ ] fool to be no real listening
that's not real or he's like me there's
no twelve-year-old warning but that's a
Vietnamese no that's Chinese right yeah
you have to order a dish and there's a
little bit of another like if you order
beef and broccoli and if there's a
little bit of chicken or a noodle from
it's someone else's dish then you know
no they cook that [ __ ] together there's
always a little kid doing homework in
the dividing off area roads and then the
waiter is taking orders and when they're
not busy they're wrapping up dumplings
mm-hmm-hmm and the little 12 year old
kid that runs the front of the register
yeah that right as soon as you sit down
they're like what do you want to order
is that authentic before you sit down
they throw the menu at you they throw
the menu and then they go what do you
want give me some time here I like the
little kids to do when they're wrapping
up the the napkins and the chopsticks
rubber-banding them for the two orders
yeah or the kid watching the [ __ ]
iPod movie water just in the back yeah
yeah yeah rocking singer we're rocking
viewers can you guys teach us about you
like just [ __ ] put in the comments
because I sound like those people that
are like oh [ __ ] I love Chinese food
yeah and I don't know anything else no
but I don't like they try to relate with
the Asian as' and I love Chinese food
and I'm all like dope I do too and then
like
you're like that connection so I think
that's that's what I am with Morocco
right now like I just had a I had a
co-worker that was a moroccan jewel
Marrakesh is it oh wait no wait Naresh I
have no idea where the [ __ ] America is I
just didn't what is good my wedding
photographer went out there for a
wedding and it looked beautiful yeah it
was okay in that case I want to go there
because those pictures with you I want
to go to Morocco anyway next JK
somewhere we don't know anything about
everything now we need to educate
ourselves we gotta have diarrhea all
over the world
mm-hmm I'm gonna show you guys this
video and this singer here she you guys
have to read the subtitles I got a read
she abuses those eyebrows that's what
god damn I got that two caterpillars on
her face let me look at those squiggly
lines all right Gina can you read out
I'll beat you here we go okay ready
Nicholas ha ha she takes the beatings
she won't forget his love she won't
forget this love even if he beats me he
won't let anyone beat me he's jealous
leading from here day
it gets piece yeah dumbass [ __ ] is this
a traditional song no like mary had a
little man she's getting a [ __ ] ton of
backlash from Moroccans what kind of
dumbass write this song herself or was
it a song that her label said you should
call out with someone on this she was
awfully proud about it but she's stand
by it and like she that was this
interview that she did on TV she's 24
years old by the way because wow she did
this interview and she was saying things
like she was like how will we how only
woman know if her husband loves her he
cares about her they respects her and
considers her an equal
she was also saying that she's not
talking about like beating to the point
where it leaves marks and like scars the
woman she's just saying like I love oh
you got a define the punch or a love
pushed like she's saying like that that
never heard of a love
she's like a man even a man in love head
slam like like you know that little
jealous jealous love I get shows that he
cares oh it's a betta stupid out of her
that's what she may be her problem
you know it's funny I just imagine like
she's like putting on her [ __ ] gloves
and like the head gear the mouth guard
show me you [ __ ] love me but imagine
she's a sick-ass fighter it's you I like
a man that can rumble I don't know she
only likes a man that can fight her the
man that's gonna be worthy enough of my
love
so she's singing this song maybe it's
like not translated right she's like I
need a man that could [ __ ] me she's like
Brianna of PARs context yeah yeah cuz
like look she looks kind of buff she's
not a frail little girl she's a woman
right
she's like Brianna ptarth she's like
she's like who's this man that can be
worthy enough to [ __ ] me up because
she's a good fighter
that's why I think I think we're gonna
see her pretty soon on UFC
she's gonna [ __ ] some [ __ ] up
watch people are taking her out of
context she's a pop singer and a [ __ ]
world-class fighter yeah so this isn't
the first time that this whole domestic
violence and Morocco thing has happened
because back in November there was a
Moroccan treat and November no vet is
that what I said no okay I got it
yeah so there was this TV channel that
faced public backlash because they were
teaching they aired this makeup tutorial
for victims of domestic violence on how
to cover that is horrible
yeah common it is real bruises I'm not
sure but this is this was the model that
they were using the beaters very
symmetrical then that is horrible oh my
god they're like hey so you know you
always get beat by your husband's well
here's the way to cover it up my
everyday [ __ ] primer and then the
normalizing it nice those are really
nice eyebrows we're great yes yeah the
show ended up apologizing because it was
it was ironic too because they aired
this two days before elimination of
violence against women Dee and so her
airing this what if they're viewing us
like I feel so sad for America and none
of the husbands love their wives over
there that's I mean that's what this one
particular girl thinks she's dumb she's
[ __ ] dumb
see there's no love in America you know
but every night before bed my man just
punches me a little bit you know like
what's weird though have you seen those
old-ass like black and white films like
the girl gets all like frantic and then
like the guy just slaps across the face
like put it together sister
[Laughter]
stop being hysterical
listen here I'm gonna set it straight
listen here you see yeah that should
happen here like in the States
maybe slaps actually worked pretty good
because when I'm hysterical when I was a
kid and my mom slap me it's like punch
your common sense comes back they're
like alright I think I'm clear now I've
seen like these terrible videos of them
like obvious arranged marriages dude
they're so bad like there's one that's
go yeah like they did like to feed the
cake to each other so like she like
feeds it to him and right when he's
about to go for a bite she pulls it away
she's trying to cute he goes and like
just throws her hand down and just walks
up I thought it was yeah that's a dude
like issues then yeah you're not
supposed to do that until like three
years in the relationship guys like that
you know when you get married and it's
all fresh especially like a arranged
marriage because you just met the person
you gotta know them before yeah I did
jump the gun
that's horrible what's wrong get to know
them and then fight but if he has the
balls to do that in front of family and
friends yeah does a Sarah should have
ever seen I hope you guys enjoyed this
video for more please subscribe to our
Channel and you can check out the last
video right here
[Music]